Queridos amigos de VisualPolitik, os hago
una pregunta, ¿quién ha ganado realmente
las últimas elecciones en los Estados Unidos,  las elecciones de mitad de mandato?
¿Ha sido el Partido Republicano el auténtico
vencedor?
¿O ha sido en cambio el Partido Demócrata?
¿Qué podemos esperar a partir de ahora?
Amigos, como sabéis, el pasado martes 7 de
noviembre de 2018 se celebraron las elecciones
de mitad de mandato:
En ellas se eligieron a 435 congresistas,
a 35 senadores y a 36 gobernadores, además
de otros mucho cargos locales como alcaldes,
jueces y sheriffs. Vamos, que las elecciones
de mitad de mandato no son ninguna broma,
hay mucho en juego.
Precisamente por eso, estas elecciones han
sido toda una contienda, una batalla encarnizada…
Y es que, veréis, en los Estados Unidos,
las elecciones de mitad de mandato además
de elegir a congresistas, senadores y gobernadores,
tienen también mucho de plebiscito sobre
la dirección política del Presidente.
Este combate lo pudimos ver, por ejemplo,
en la mismísima, Texas; un bastión republicano
desde hace décadas donde a punto estuvieron
de escoger a un senador demócrata.
[Un momento, ¿un demócrata ganando hoy en
Texas, en la tierra de los cow boys? Pues,
amigos, ya no parece tan improbable.]
Pues bien, nuestra misión en este
vídeo va echar un vistazo a las claves de
las elecciones, a los tantos logrados por
el Partido Demócrata y a los tantos conseguidos
por el Partido Republicano. Y sobre todo,
también, veremos qué podemos esperar de
aquí a las presidenciales de 2020.
Atentos.
(¿VICTORIA DEMÓCRATA?)
Muchos esperaban una enorme ola azul - que
es el color del Partido Demócrata.
(Sin embargo, los resultados han sido mucho
más discretos y los republicanos han logrado
consolidar y ampliar su mayoría en el poderoso
Senado norteamericano y defenderse relativamente
bien en la elección de gobernadores.)
Ahora bien, esperad un momento, porque decir
eso… es dejarnos muchas cosas en el tintero.
Lo que vivimos el pasado martes fue una reñida
lucha que dibujó dos países muy diferentes,
por una lado las grandes zonas urbanas, mayoritariamente demócratas,
y por otro lado las zonas rurales,
que siguieron apoyando ferreamente al Partido
Republicano.
Mirad, este es el mapa que dejó la elección
a la Cámara de Representantes, que fue la
elección que se produjo en todo el país.
Pues bien, tal y como veis, el mapa es rojo
- el color del Partido Republicano. Pero,
amigos, no os dejéis engañar por las apariencias.
Lo cierto es que los demócratas aquí lograron
un resultado bastante notable, especialmente
en lo que a voto popular se refiere.
Fijaos, de los 435 distritos en los que se
divide el país, en ni más ni menos que 317
el Partido Demócrata mejoró su resultados,
en promedio en unos 10 puntos…
Y aun más,, aunque en Estados Unidos los recuentos
son muy pero que muy lentos, la diferencia
total que los demócratas sacaron a los republicanos
puede estar en torno a los 7 puntos…
[Y, miradme bien, eso en términos de voto
es una... paliza.]
Sí, sí, ya sé que en Estados Unidos eso
no es importante… luego lo veremos, pero
de momento: tanto para los demócratas.
El caso es que todo esto, claro, se ha traducido
en que este partido, el Partido Demócrata
se ha hecho con la mayoría de la Cámara
de Representantes recuperando entre 30 y 37
escaños.
[Sí, en el momento de hacer este vídeo,
varios días más tarde, aún hay muchas carreras
sin cerrar.]
Pero aquí no termina todo.
(Además los demócratas recuperaron 7 gobiernos
estatales, su mejor resultado desde 1982:
Illinois, Nevada, Maine, Nuevo México, Michigan,
Kansas Wisconsin. En estos 3 últimos estados,
por cierto, Donald Trump, ganó en las últimas
presidenciales.)
Y esto además de suponer más poder es algo
crucial de cara a las elecciones 2020. Los
gobernadores tienen influencia y muchos recursos.
Eso sí, por los pelos, perdieron, Florida.
Respecto al Senado, es verdad que los republicanos
han ampliado su ventaja, pero en unas elecciones
donde los demócratas defendían 26 escaños
y los republicanos tan solo 9. Escaños…
elegidos hace 6 años, antes de que fuera
siquiera imaginable el terremoto político
que ha vivido el país.
Ahora bien, amigos, estos son los resultados
más visibles pero las elecciones nos han
dejado mucha más información.
Atentos.
(A PIE DE URNA)
Lo siento, Donald Trump es un presidente bastante
impopular, más que sus predecesores.
No lo decimos en VisualPolitik, lo dicen las
encuestas y ahora también los votos.
Amigos, a falta de resultados definitivos,
tal vez lo más preocupante para el Partido
Republicano es ver lo que está ocurriendo
con la composición del voto.
Veréis, me explico. Los demócratas han arrasado
entre las minorías, entre los jóvenes y
entre las mujeres. Ahora, incluso ya ni siquiera
pierden entre las mujeres blancas, un segmento
de voto en el que los dos partidos han empatado.
De hecho, los republicanos sólo han ganado
entre los hombres blancos.
El votante promedio del partido republicano es
un hombre blanco, de mediana edad, que vive
en áreas rurales o pequeños núcleos urbanos…
y que no tiene estudios universitarios. Sí,
entre la población con estudios superiores
los demócratas han ganado el voto por 20
puntos.
Y esto, es un problema.
(A pesar del buen momento económico que viven
los Estados Unidos, el perfil político de
Donald Trump está dejando fuera al Partido
Republicano de los segmentos de población
que más crecen, y también de las ciudades
y los espacios con mayor nivel académico...
que a largo plazo suelen tener mucha influencia
y son sobre los que pivotan los nuevos modelos
económicos.)
Ni ciudades, ni profesionales con estudios
superiores, ni mujeres, ni minorías. Ese
es el Partido Republicano que está construyendo
Donald Trump.
(Esto es lo que explica que incluso en un
estado tan importante para el Partido Republicano
como Texas, los demócratas estuvieran a punto
de ganar, con uno de sus candidatos revelación,
Beto O'Rourke, la carrera al senado. Al final
el republicano Ted Cruz mantuvo el escaño,
pero la diferencia fue muy pequeña. Texas
empieza a ser un estado en juego)
Claro que, amigos, este partido también ha
tenido motivos para sacar pecho. Atentos.
(¿TRIUNFO REPUBLICANO?)
Un momento, un momento, esperad.
No nos equivoquemos, el Partido Republicano,
también tiene motivos para sacar pecho. El
cambio de color político en la Cámara de
Representantes respecto a la Casa Blanca en
las elecciones de mitad de mandato es algo
habitual.
(De hecho, en escaños - que no en votos - los
republicanos han perdido menos asientos que
por ejemplo, Bill Clinton en 1994 o Barack
Obama en 2010. Y ambos presidentes lograron
2 años después la reelección.
Además, como hemos visto, por un motivo o
por otro, el caso es que también lograron
afianzar y ampliar su mayoría en el Senado,
con lo que la Administración Trump se asegura
poder frenar las iniciativas legislativas
demócratas y mantiene la capacidad para confirmar
jueces y miembros de su administración.)
Además, estas elecciones prácticamente han
evitado que un posible proceso de impeachment
- que necesita el refrendo del senado - pueda
tener éxito.
Y tal vez lo más importante de todo. Cómo
sabéis en Estados Unidos el voto popular
no vale para mucho, por no decir para nada.
Lo que cuenta es el numero de representantes
que se obtengan…
Y amigos la relación entre representantes
y votos no es ni muchos perfecta. Los estados
con menos población están sobrepresentados
y son, mayoritariamente republicanos. Esto
es lo que explica que que Hillary Clinton
ganará por 3 millones de votos a Donald Trump
pero perdiera la presidencia.
O también, fijaos, en esta ilustración.
[¿Ahora entendéis el buen resultado que
el Partido Republicano ha tenido en el Senado?]
(Este motivo es lo que explica, que ante las
elecciones presidenciales algunos estados
sean más importantes que otros. En unas elecciones
presidenciales, dado el reparto de pesos,
lo más importante no son los bastiones sino
los estados en disputa, en los que pueda ganar
un partido u otro.
Y a decir verdad, amigos, aquí el equipo
de Trump ha tenido algunos éxitos muy importantes:
ha logrado hacerse tanto con el senador y
todo apunta a que también con el gobierno
estatal de Florida , así como con el gobernador
de Ohio y el de Iowa.)
Y, amigos, Florida, Ohio y Iowa son tres de
los estados más importantes de cara a las
presidenciales.
En cualquier caso, en una economía que marcha
a toda velocidad, con la menor tasa de desempleo
en 17 años años y una reducción de impuestos,
haber obtenido un resultado tan pobre debería
ser preocupante entre las filas republicanas.
El hecho de que en vez de sacar pecho hayan
tenido que volver a recurrir al miedo… incluso
con anuncios racistas… muestra mucho cual
está siendo el modelo de país que está
dibujando Donald Trump.
Donald Trump no va de la mano de los entornos
más prósperos ni busca cohesionar al país.
Su estrategia política pasa por dividir,
polarizar y alimentar el odio.
(“El presidente Trump ha hecho 6.240 falsas
o engañosas afirmaciones en 649 días". Washington
Post)
Pero dicho esto, la gran pregunta que podemos
hacernos es ¿Qué va a pasar ahora?¿Que
supondrán estas elecciones? Atentos.
(¿Y AHORA QUÉ?)
El juego político en los Estados Unidos,
se pone aún más al rojo vivo. Controlar
la Cámara de Representantes es más importante
de lo que parece.
Pero… ¿Qué es lo que pueden y no pueden
hacer ahora los démocratas?
Pues… vereis. Gracias al control que ahora
pasan a tener sobre la Cámara de Representantes,
los demócratas van a poder investigar a Trump
y al Gobierno.
Me explico. Aprobar una ley requiere una mayoría
en las dos cámaras del Capitolio, en la Cámara
de Representantes y en el Senado, así como
la firma del presidente. [Por eso el tema
de aprobar nuevas leyes va a estar muy complicado].
Sin embargo, abrir una investigación sobre
el Presidente o su gobierno solo requiere
del control de algunas comisiones de la Cámara
de Representantes.
Y los demócratas tienen ganas.
Ahora van a poder solicitar sus declaraciones
de impuestos - que Trump se ha negado a enseñar
-, emitir citaciones para investigar sus negocios,
sus posibles relaciones con operaciones de
blanqueo de dinero o muchas de las polémicas
que ha tenido, como el despido al exdirector
del FBI James Comey o los pagos a sus sus
supuestas ex amantes.
(También van a poder controlar el presupuesto…
porque eso es una responsabilidad de la Cámara
y aprobar proyectos de ley que obliguen a
los republicanos a retratarse en el Senado.
E, incluso, , llegado el caso, podrían comenzar
un Impeachment aunque no tuviera recorrido
en el Senado.)
En fin, amigos, como veis, con estas elecciones
los demócratas han vuelto al terreno política…
y con Trump en la Casa Blanca creo que podemos
esperar muchos enfrentamientos.
Pero ahora turno para ti, vamos con una gran
pregunta… ¿Cómo valoras los dos primeros
años de Donald Trump al frente de la Casa
Blanca? De 1 a 5, dejanos tu respuesta en
esta encuesta y también en los comentarios.
Si te ha gustado este vídeo dale a like y
no olvides suscribirte a VisualPolitik
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.